Mais bonsoir à toutes et à tous,
Merci d'être au rendez vous pour ce
dernier Café des sciences de la saison.
Ce soir, on va parler des maladies
rares avec Sylvie Audon.
Merci Sylvie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation.
Vous êtes généticienne au CHU de Rennes
et vous coordonnera un centre
qui s'appelle le clade Ouest
pour centres de référence, Anomalies
du développement et syndromes
mal de l'Ouest.
Vous êtes donc spécialiste
des maladies rares et je le précise,
vous avez quand même copiloté
la rédaction du troisième plan
national Maladies rares,
qui s'étend de 2018 à 2023.
Et ce soir, avec vous, on va parler
de ces maladies qui sont finalement pas
si rares que ça puisqu'elles
touchent près de 5% des Français.
Et on va donc faire le point sur ce qu'est
une maladie rare.
Quels sont les enjeux
à la fois technologiques et politiques
qui entourent le sujet ?
Des questions que se posent les chercheurs
et les chercheuses aujourd'hui ?
Et vous qui êtes dans le public,
eh bien, n'hésitez pas
à poser vos questions dans un micro
qui est prévu pour circuler.
Et voilà, vous pourrez intervenir
tout au long de l'échange.
Peut être Sylvie Pour commencer,
une question
toute simple mais importante
qu'est ce qu'une maladie rare, en fait
importante ?
Merci beaucoup
tout le monde dans votre présence
et merci à Violette et toute l'équipe
de Sciences Ouest de m'avoir invitée.
Donc la définition, en fait,
elle est toute simple c'est
des maladies qui touchent moins de
une personne sur 2000
par rapport aux maladies communes
comme le cancer,
les maladies cardiovasculaires, et cetera
Après,
il y a des maladies rares, fréquentes
on va dire comme la mucoviscidose,
l'hémophilie a des maladies
dont tout le monde a entendu parler,
et puis des maladies ultra rares
ou quelquefois
c'est une ou deux personnes en France
et on va retrouver des cas
quelque part dans le monde.
Donc c'est très large. Voilà.
Mais la définition, c'est moins d'une
personne sur 2000, c'est vraiment
le seul élément de définition,
peu importe le type de maladie ensuite.
Oui, oui, parce que c'est
une bonne remarque en fait.
Alors moi je suis pédiatre à l'origine,
mais spécialisé après en génétique et
il y a quand même
80% des maladies rares
qui sont d'origine génétique.
C'est pour ça que les généticiens
s'intéressent souvent aux maladies rares.
Mais il y a quand même 20% des maladies
rares qui ne sont pas d'origine génétique.
Certaines d'ailleurs.
On ne sait pas de quelle origine
elles sont et
il y a des maladies
auto immunes, auto inflammatoires, etc
qui sont très rares.
Donc ça n'est pas que le champ
de la génétique, c'est 80% quand même
d'origine génétique.
Et donc aujourd'hui on recense
environ 8000 maladies rares dans le monde,
mais on continue
d'en découvrir tous les ans.
C'est bien ça ?
Oui, je dirais presque tous les mois.
Parce que, en fait,
avec toutes ces nouvelles techniques
qui apparaissent, notamment
ce qu'on appelle le séquençage du génome,
on découvre des nouveaux gènes,
des nouvelles maladies
qu'on apprend petit à petit à décrire.
Donc c'est un monde qui est
en pleine explosion, on va dire.
Je pense que c'est important
pour la suite de l'échange de préciser
la structuration de la prise
en charge de ces maladies
en France parce que c'est une organisation
qui est un peu particulière.
En fait, on a 23 filières nationales
qui regroupent des catégories de maladies
et à l'intérieur de ces filières,
on a des centres de référence
dont celui que
vous coordonnées. C'est ça ?
Bravo !
Donc effectivement,
il y a une structuration très importante.
La France est un peu
un exemple qui est copié
par les autres pays d'Europe.
Donc en fait
il y a des centres de référence
qui sont des centres experts, qui
regroupent des équipes multidisciplinaires
dans tout un tas de champs.
Vous avez des centres maladies
rares, dermatologiques,
maladies rares, de la coagulation
ou des maladies neuromusculaires.
Moi, je m'occupe plus de tout ce qui est
syndrome mal informatif,
déficience intellectuelle.
On a deux centres de référence
dans le service.
Donc je n'ai pas,
Je ne suis pas présenté au départ,
mais donc je suis responsable
du service de génétique clinique au aussi
à CHU à Rennes.
Donc nous, on voit les patients,
on voit les malades
et donc on a plusieurs secteurs
dans le service.
Et il y a à peu près
un tiers de notre activité
qui est consacrée à ces maladies rares,
avec différents centres de référence
qui sont financés du coup
avec une équipe multidisciplinaire
et puis des centres de compétences
qui sont des relais.
Finalement,
au plus près des gens sur le territoire,
avec tout un tas de thématiques
dans le service,
on est aussi centre de compétences,
par exemple
pour les maladies neuromusculaires,
les maladies métaboliques, et cetera.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment l'échelle
au niveau du territoire et national,
parce que certains centres de référence
sont vraiment nationaux.
Et puis au dessus, il y a un chapeau,
un peu par thèmes
les filières qui associent alors non
seulement les centres de référence,
mais aussi les associations
de personnes malades, les laboratoires
de diagnostic,
laboratoires de recherche, les
et même certains industriels.
C'est très large en fait,
et il y avait un maillon
un peu qui manquait.
Et donc on a essayé de le combler.
Et maintenant il y a des dispositifs
qui sont plus régionaux,
qui connaissent bien
les acteurs régionaux des plateformes.
Donc on a une plateforme en Bretagne
qui est coordonnée à Rennes,
mais avec une antenne à Brest
qui s'appelle Rare Breizh, la plateforme
d'expertise maladies rares Breizh,
qui connaît bien
les acteurs locaux et qui fait le relais
des filières sur le territoire.
Donc ça paraît compliqué vu de loin.
En fait,
on a vraiment une bonne structuration.
Le problème, c'est
que les gens la connaissent pas.
Et le gros challenge du futur plan,
justement, ça va être de mieux
faire connaître des acteurs de terrain.
Je sais qu'il y a des élèves infirmiers
dans l'assemblée, les personnes
qui sont vraiment auprès des patients,
les paramédicaux,
les médecins généralistes, mais aussi
tous ceux qui sont près des patients.
Donc ça peut être aussi les éducateurs,
les et puis le milieu médico social,
et cetera Donc là, on a un gros boulot
à faire de d'information, de formation.
Y compris aussi
dans les formations initiales.
Oui, parce qu'en fait,
l'objectif, c'est d'intégrer le malade
le plus rapidement possible
dans ce circuit là que vous décrivez
pour faciliter le diagnostic
et le traitement.
Ça, c'est l'idée.
Mais en pratique, c'est pas assistant.
C'est simple,
on estime qu'il y a un quart des patients.
C'est ça qui attend plus de cinq ans
avant d'être diagnostiqué.
Certains ne le sont jamais.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle l'errance diagnostique et c'est
un problème qui est particulièrement
important chez les maladies rares.
Ben oui,
parce que, par définition, c'est rare.
C'est à l'Irak, c'est rare. Donc
il est important
que les professionnels
soient sensibilisés,
ce qui est la culture du doute,
comme on dit,
et qui se pose
La question est voilà, j'y comprends rien.
Mais si c'était une maladie rare
et surtout savoir où l'adresser
parce qu'on ne peut pas demander
à un médecin généraliste,
par exemple, de tout connaître,
c'est pas possible non plus.
On connaît pas tout.
Mais par contre, connaître les circuits,
savoir où adresser,
savoir où il y a l'équipe experte
qui va pouvoir démêler les choses
et puis prendre en charge.
Bien sûr,
c'est finalement le plus important.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment ce qu'on appelle
l'errance diagnostique.
C'est la personne bien que voilà
qui est clair.
Comme son nom l'indique, de professionnel
en professionnel, on lui dit que c'est
que c'est rien, que c'est dans la tête.
Ou alors que ces symptômes,
aucun rapport entre eux, et cetera.
Donc ça, c'est l'errance.
Et effectivement, il y a un quart
des patients qui attendent au moins quatre
ou cinq ans pour avant
d'avoir un diagnostic et dans les maladies
rares, on a encore la moitié des patients
qui n'ont pas de diagnostic.
Donc il y a du boulot
et il y a quatre 20 15%.
Je vous assomme de chiffres.
Après, j'arrête de ces patients
qui n'ont pas de traitement spécifique.
Il y a que 5% des gens
qui ont vraiment un traitement spécifique.
Ça ne veut pas dire que les autres,
on s'en occupe par ça.
Mais il faut les prendre en charge,
bien sûr, et le mieux
possible
dans leur parcours de soins et de vie.
Et il y a plein de choses à faire,
mais en tout cas un traitement vraiment
spécifique de la maladie,
il y en a encore très peu.
Je ne sais pas
s'il y a déjà des questions.
Oui, je souhaite, il y a des questions.
Je me posais la question.
Parmi toutes ces maladies rares, arrivez
vous avec les statistiques des différents
symptômes, et cetera,
à trouver des points communs
entre certaines maladies qui apparaissent
complètement différentes
mais qui ont des symptômes communs ?
Peut être que ce serait peut être
une piste de recherche ?
Peut être tout à fait.
Vous avez tout à fait raison.
En fait, c'est
grâce à un travail souvent en réseau
aussi que
l'on avance.
C'est à dire que
on travaille beaucoup
dans le milieu des maladies
rares par ce qu'on appelle des RCP
les réunions de concertation
pluridisciplinaire où on nous confronte
un peu les cas de nos patients,
où on n'a pas de diagnostic
justement en fonction de leurs symptômes.
Moi, je travaille beaucoup
dans le domaine de la morphologie.
Les certains patients ont des
une apparence physique
particulière, des difficultés
cognitives,
des symptômes neurologiques associés,
quelquefois des malformations, et cetera
Et finalement, c'est en en parlant
et en regroupant avec d'autres cas
qu'on avance à l'échelle
déjà de notre centre,
beaucoup à l'échelle interrégionale.
Nous, on a des réunions tous les mois
au niveau de la région.
Et puis et puis de plus en plus
à l'échelle nationale et européenne.
C'est à dire que, en fait,
le plan maladies
rares français a été un petit peu copié.
Petit à petit, il y a des plans maladies
rares qui se construisent
dans les différents pays d'Europe,
avec des réseaux européens de référence
qui sont un peu en miroir de ce qui existe
au niveau des filières en France.
Et il.
Les données sont partagées.
Il y a même un Facebook du gène,
si on peut dire,
qui s'appelle dine matcher où.
On partage par exemple des variations
dans qu'on
a trouvé dans l'ADN avec tel symptôme
qu'il y a quelqu'un dans le monde
qui a la même chose et en fait,
on lance le truc.
Et puis au bout de cinq minutes,
il y a un Chinois, un Américain
et un Asiatique qui vous a répondu ?
Oui, j'avais une question si ça marche.
J'avais mis une question
sur les réponses médicales
parce que moi,
je suis atteint de dystonie.
C'est une maladie rare et donc
j'étais dans l'errance médicale
et je me posais la question.
Maintenant, à l'heure actuelle,
avec l'intelligence
artificielle du petit,
est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas envisager
ou est ce qu'il
y a des recherches qui sont faites
justement avec l'intelligence artificielle
sur le profilage,
une sorte de profilage pour
diminuer cette différence médicale ?
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas une chose
qui va diminuer les errances médicales.
Il faut déjà que
la personne, elle, soit quand même vu
par les hommes, par les bonnes personnes.
Il faut de l'humain quand même à la base,
après que le professionnel s'aide d'outils
avec de l'intelligence artificielle.
Oui, bien sûr.
De plus en plus, on s'en sert
sans forcément le savoir d'ailleurs.
Mais moi, depuis que je fais ce métier
très vite, on a utilisé par exemple
des outils d'aide au diagnostic.
On rentre les signes
et puis ça sort une liste de diagnostics.
Alors des fois,
ça c'est vraiment n'importe quoi.
Donc faut quand même
est un peu critique, mais,
mais c'est de plus en plus sophistiqué.
Cela dit, ça ne fait pas tout quand même.
Dire qu'il faut
c'est c'est un peu comme les
je ne sais pas moi les radiologues
maintenant qui vont
se faire interpréter leur les radiologues
qui font de façon automatique.
Mais s'ils n'ont pas un oeil critique,
ça peut quand même être
un peu catastrophique aussi.
Donc je pense que c'est un mélange subtil
entre effectivement
le patient qui lui sait ce qu'il a.
Il est
son propre expert.
Les professionnels qui sont autour de lui,
qui travaillent en réseau si possible.
C'est même indispensable,
surtout dans les maladies rares.
On peut plus travailler tout seul
et avec l'aide d'instruments
d'intelligence artificielle bien sûr.
De plus en plus.
Je ne sais pas
si je réponds à votre question.
Bonsoir, justement,
vous parliez des patients.
Est ce que vous travaillez
avec les collectifs de patients
qui se regroupent
et est ce que vous faites
ce qu'on peut appeler
des recherches participatives ?
Ah ça, c'est une super bonne question.
C'est vraiment,
je pense, l'avenir de la recherche. Ça.
En fait,
on parlait d'intelligence artificielle.
Il y a de plus en plus de constitution
de bases de données
et les bases de données.
Traditionnellement, c'était
un médecin qui rentrait des données
dans un registre ou
ou un assistant de recherche clinique
qui rend des données,
et cetera De plus en plus,
ce sont les lois.
Il y a des bases de données participatives
où le patient rentre ces données
et avec plein de détails.
Évidemment que le professionnel,
lui, connaît pas.
Et c'est un outil extraordinaire
pour mieux
connaître l'histoire naturelle
des maladies
et secondairement, c'est ça
qui va permettre vraiment de savoir
si des traitements sont efficaces.
Parce que si vous connaissez pas bien
l'histoire naturelle de la maladie, ultra
rare des fois, comment voulez vous savoir
si un traitement a vraiment eu un effet ?
Et donc ça, c'est c'est
en pleine expansion.
C'est un travail
qui est fait de plus en plus à l'échelle
européenne, de plus en plus.
Je ne sais pas
si j'ai répondu à votre question initiale.
Par contre, c'est
peut être juste dans le prolongement,
justement,
comme on parle du patient
potentiellement de patients experts.
Est ce que vous développez
des travaux en lien
par exemple avec le Cap Bretagne ?
Alors ?
Nous, on travaille énormément
dans le domaine des maladies rares,
avec les associations de personnes malades
qui sont souvent affiliées à l'Alliance
maladies
rares,
qui est une fédération d'associations.
On a pas mal de liens, aussi
bien au niveau de l'enseignement
avec France Asso Santé.
Le Cap, c'est un peu moins ?
Oui, mais
par exemple, au niveau de notre plateforme
d'expertise
maladies rares.
Dans la gouvernance, on a des patients.
Vous voyez,
demain
on organise une journée régionale l'InVS.
Je ne sais pas comment ça se passait.
D'ailleurs avec les greffes,
mais en tout cas, on l'organise
et il y a toute une partie
qui a été construite avec les associations
de personnes malades,
Donc contre.
Et on travaille beaucoup avec eux
et de plus en plus
dans les enseignements aussi.
Par exemple, on coordonne une unité
d'enseignement à la fac de médecine
sur les maladies rares.
Il y a plusieurs cours entre guillemets,
parce que ce n'est pas
des cours très traditionnels
avec des patients,
des patients
qui témoignent de leur parcours.
Un patient qui participe aux cours
sur l'éducation thérapeutique.
On construit aussi
des programmes d'éducation thérapeutique.
C'est connu depuis longtemps
dans les maladies communes
comme le diabète, l'asthme, et cetera
Mais là, de plus en plus sur des maladies
rares justement.
Et et qui mieux
qu'un patient à temps connaît sa maladie ?
Ils souvent y sont très, très experts,
beaucoup plus que les professionnels
sur certains aspects.
Donc voilà, il interviennent aussi dans
des programmes d'éducation thérapeutique.
Ça, c'est
aller là, c'est vraiment les maladies.
Rares sont une.
Un milieu où il y a des expérimentations
comme ça qui sont vraiment
fréquentes, peut être plus que
dans les maladies communes.
Mais en fait, ce qui sert aux maladies
rares, zéro
maladies communes et inversement.
Je crois qu'il ne faut pas.
Il ne faut pas
qu'il y ait de clivage non plus
depuis depuis quelques années pour réduire
les diagnostics dont on parlait
tout à l'heure, on mise beaucoup
sur le séquençage haut débit.
Est ce que vous pourriez peut être nous
expliquer en quoi ça consiste ?
Et puis pourquoi c'est cette technologie ?
Elle est si prometteuse.
Alors
juste un petit historique.
Je ne veux pas faire trop long quand même.
Mais moi,
quand j'ai commencé la génétique,
l'examen génétique
ou qu'une fois que vous aviez fait
le caryotype, l'analyse
des chromosomes, compter les chromosomes,
c'était à peu près fini.
Donc, après, il y a eu l'arrivée
de l'identification de certains gènes,
la mucoviscidose par exemple, en 89.
Mais il y avait tout un tas de patients
où on n'avait pas d'idée diagnostique.
En fait un ça,
ça va d'aller étudier de tels gènes.
Déjà, faut qu'ils soient connus.
Et deuxièmement,
il faut avoir l'idée du diagnostic.
Mais il y a plein de maladies
où Justement, on ne sait pas ce qu'est
le patient.
Je pense au domaine, par exemple
de la déficience intellectuelle,
anomalies du développement,
et cetera C'est extrêmement hétérogène
et donc ce qu'apporte
ces techniques de séquençage haut débit,
c'est qu'on peut
sont arrivés d'abord les panels,
c'est à dire qu'on a réussi
à séquencer, à analyser,
mettons par exemple, une centaine de gènes
impliqués dans un groupe de maladies.
Donc c'est déjà ça a été un gros progrès.
Il y a une dizaine d'années.
Et puis, petit à petit,
il y a eu l'arrivée de ce qu'on appelle
l'analyse d'exorcisme, c'est à dire
de l'analyse de tous les gènes connus
qui codent pour des protéines.
Donc ça aussi,
ça a été encore une avancée.
A chaque fois, on gagne,
on va dire dix 20% de diagnostics.
Et puis là maintenant
est arrivé dans le domaine du soin
et non plus uniquement de la recherche.
L'analyse du génome,
le génome, c'est à dire
tous les gènes connus,
mais aussi les régions entre les gènes.
Est ce qu'on pensait
que ça servait à rien au début ?
Mais en fait, si ça a quand même un rôle,
parce que
on s'aperçoit que quand il
quand il manque des bouts entre les gènes,
il y a quand même des problèmes
et dans la conformation de l'ADN,
et cetera Donc donc là
on en est à l'analyse du génome.
Et même avec ça,
et même quand on suspecte fortement
une maladie génétique, on en est encore
qu'à peu près à la moitié des diagnostics
qu'on n'a pas encore fini.
Donc vont arriver d'autres techniques.
Elles arrivent déjà dans l'analyse
de l'ARN, l'analyse des protéines,
des produits métaboliques.
À chaque fois,
ça s'appelle protéome, métabolisme,
et cetera Et l'épigénétique aussi.
L'effet de certains produits
ou l'environnement sur les gènes ?
Donc voilà, on progresse à petits pas,
mais à chaque fois,
c'est une petite marche.
Donc ce qu'apporte
ces techniques de séquençage haut débit,
c'est que même quand vous n'avez
pas d'idée diagnostique,
vous pouvez
quand même trouver des diagnostics
en séquence.
En tout.
Le problème, c'est que maintenant,
il y a des machines très performantes.
Mais vous imaginez bien que derrière, ça
génère un nombre de données incroyable
et que le problème, c'est
plus tellement la production des données,
c'est surtout l'interprétation.
Donc il y a un énorme travail
de bio informatique en fait.
Maintenant,
la génétique, c'est vraiment le trio,
le clinicien qui voit le patient,
le bio informaticien et le biologiste.
C'est vraiment un trio qui ne peut pas
fonctionner l'un sans l'autre.
Et surtout derrière,
il y a plein de travail
pour trier tous ces variants
parce que ça va générer des millions
de variations
par rapport à des ADN de référence.
Donc il faut savoir extraire ce qui
va être vraiment la cause de la maladie.
Donc c'est un domaine qui est mouvant.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Il y a un sujet
qui revient souvent maintenant,
c'est le microbiote.
Est ce que l'analyse de microbiote,
c'est à dire l'excès
ou le défaut de certains
de certaines bactéries spécifiques
tout au long du transit comme ça ?
Est ce que ça pourrait être sujet
à une solution pour certaines maladies ?
Peut être.
Moi, je ne suis pas
du tout spécialiste de ces maladies là.
Mais oui, la réponse est oui.
Il y a, il y a même des bouquins
qui ont été créés là dessus
sur le deuxième cerveau.
Donc effectivement,
il y a toute une génétique du microbiote
qui peut influencer avec l'immunothérapie.
Mais oui, oui, entre autres.
Alors là,
je ne veux pas trop
m'aventurer sur ce terrain
parce que c'est
vraiment pas ma spécialité.
Mais la réponse est oui.
Bien sûr,
c'est un autre champ de recherche
et il y a des maladies rares,
probablement dues
à des anomalies du microbiote.
C'est peut être juste pour suivre un peu
dans ce sens, c'est à dire qu'on
parle beaucoup maintenant de d'exposés
mais d'exposition ou tout
au cours des âges de la vie.
Et ce que vous disiez, c'est qu'au
niveau des maladies rares,
il y en a au moins quatre 20 15%.
On n'a pas forcément de traitement.
Alors je ne sais pas
si, en analysant les maladies rares
en question, il serait possible,
mais c'est une question que je me pose.
Il serait possible de les prévenir
à partir du moment
où des hypothèses fortes montreraient
que du fait des expositions
tout au long des âges de la vie,
on aurait la possibilité de prévenir
un certain nombre de ces maladies rares.
Mais alors peut être
que je délire complètement dans ma tête
et parce que ça suppose effectivement là,
pour le coup, un travail en lien étroit
avec tout un tas de professionnels
qui évoluent
dans le champ de la santé et beaucoup
plus, beaucoup plus globalement.
Donc je ne sais pas si ça,
ce sont des pistes
qu'on commence à interroger ou là on est,
on est encore trop tôt dans le process,
alors c'est dans ces.
C'est une excellente question,
c'est tout Le domaine de l'épigénétique
aussi, c'est à dire
l'influence de l'environnement sur
sur les gènes, en fait, sur la génétique,
oui. Alors effectivement, jusqu'à
maintenant, c'était un peu de monde
de recherche différent.
Il y avait ceux qui travaillaient
sur l'environnement, l'expo zoom,
et cetera puis ceux qui travaillaient
sur la génétique et en fait.
Bien sûr qu'on se rend compte
qu'il y a des interactions
gène l'environnement,
on le suppose depuis longtemps,
mais de plus en plus, on peut le prouver.
C'est à dire qu'il y a des
ce qu'on appelle des signatures
particulières dans certaines maladies,
des profils de méthylation,
en particulier.
Il y a un autre champ.
Ce que vous décrivez aussi, par exemple,
c'est
ce qu'on fait
quand on fait du dépistage néonatal.
C'est à dire que je prends un exemple
qui va, je pense, tous vous parler.
Quand un bébé naît, on lui fait.
On lui met une petite goutte
de sang sur le buvard.
Vous savez, dans les premiers jours de vie
et on détecte
plusieurs maladies dont, par exemple,
je prends la maladie la plus historique.
Elle s'appelle la phénylcétonurie.
C'est une maladie métabolique.
Il manque une enzyme
qui métaboliser les protéines.
Si on donne à ce bébé
un régime pauvre en phénylalanine,
qui est la protéine qui s'accumule
de façon anormale,
cet enfant va évoluer tout à fait
normalement.
Quand il n'était pas traité avant
les années 70,
c'était des encéphalopathie profonds
quand même, ces enfants là.
Donc on a modifié finalement
de façon préventive
leur environnement quelque part.
Donc ce n'était pas encore
de la grande science, mais quand même,
ça a été un progrès fantastique.
Donc là, ce qui se profile,
mais ce n'est pas encore,
c'est pas fait encore,
c'est d'élargir de plus en plus
ces dépistages néonataux
justement pour intervenir avant
qu'il y ait les symptômes
et donc ce que vous êtes vraiment
dans l'actualité parce qu'on est en train
de réfléchir à un projet pilote.
L'ajustement
peut être entre l'Ouest et l'Est pour
faire
du dépistage néonatal beaucoup plus large
par les techniques de génomique,
ce qui n'est pas fait pour l'instant.
Pour l'instant, ce sont des techniques
de plus classiques de biochimie.
En fait, on dose des produits.
Donc c'est encore c'est
pas encore d'actualité.
Complète, mais
on va peut être y venir.
On parle de dépistage néonatal néonatal,
mais on a aussi
un dépistage prénatal
qui peut arriver pendant la grossesse.
Oui, alors en prénatal, il y a plusieurs
monde, on va dire.
Il y a
le dépistage néonatal anténatal par don.
Ça peut être par exemple, ce qu'on propose
aux femmes enceintes qui le souhaitent.
C'est pas du tout obligatoire,
mais les femmes qui le souhaitent peuvent.
On peut leur estimer le risque
qu'elles ont d'avoir un enfant.
Trisomie 21 par exemple.
Donc ça, c'est du dépistage
à partir d'une prise de sang,
plus la mesure de la clarté
buccale, plus leur âge,
c'est mouliné dans une machine.
C'est de l'intelligence artificielle.
Donc ça, c'est du dépistage.
Par contre,
ce qui est aussi très développé,
c'est le diagnostic anténatal,
c'est à dire
la surveillance des grossesses
par échographie
et en fonction de certains signes,
on peut être amené maintenant à faire.
Alors on fait depuis longtemps
des amniocentèse.
Mais ce qu'on faisait de façon
traditionnelle,
c'était un simple caryotype.
Donc maintenant, on peut aller plus loin
et dans certains cas, même proposé
une analyse des zones.
Quand on suspecte une maladie grave
ou une maladie sur laquelle on peut agir.
Voilà. Donc
en fait, ce qu'on.
Là où on avance en postnatal
petit à petit, arrive en prénatal
et vous le disiez,
si on avance un peu dans le temps,
une fois que la avec les adultes
et même avec les enfants.
Vous le disiez
au début de cet échange avec les maladies
rares, peut être un peu plus
qu'avec les autres maladies.
On accompagne un parcours de vie
autant qu'un parcours de soins,
en faisant particulièrement attention
à la santé mentale des patients
et aussi de leurs proches. Pourquoi est
ce que c'est si important en fait
alors ?
C'est important parce que c'est bien
faire.
Des fois, il n'y a pas de diagnostic.
Et même quand il y a un diagnostic,
en fait,
on n'a pas forcément de traitement.
Donc c'est très important
de les accompagner
en connaissant mieux aussi les maladies
et donc ce qu'il faut surveiller.
Et on peut améliorer quand même
plein de choses, diminuer
certains handicaps.
Et puis il y a tout le côté
médico social, c'est à dire
aider toutes ces personnes
dans leurs démarches médico sociales.
C'est le rôle des centres de référence,
aussi bien de
qui soit un petit peu moins perdu.
C'est à dire ?
Concrètement,
comment est ce que vous vous y prenez ?
Ça passe par des assistants sociaux,
des psychologues.
Alors, dans les centres maladies rares,
oui, c'est des équipes
pluri disciplinaires par définition.
Sinon, on n'est pas labellisé. Donc
oui, il y a infirmière,
psychologue,
neuropsychologue, assistant social
et toutes ces personnes
sont au moins aussi importantes, sinon
plus pour certains aspects
que les que les médecins.
Chacun a son rôle.
Et puis pour les personnes
qui sont perdues justement,
qui sont un peu en errance, et cetera,
il y a ces fameuses plateformes
d'expertise maladies rares là,
qui peuvent aider.
C'est à dire que les gens appellent.
Et dans notre équipe,
on a un assistant social,
justement,
qui est une infirmière puéricultrice
et une chef de projet
et l'équivalent à Brest.
Et on aide les gens
à s'orienter le mieux possible.
Donc oui, c'est un prendre en charge
des personnes.
C'est vrai pour les maladies communes,
mais c'est peut être encore plus vrai
pour les maladies rares
où vous êtes plus isolés par définition
parce que personne ne connaît
votre maladie.
C'est, c'est aussi
beaucoup de l'accompagnement,
c'est à dire qu'il y a le diagnostic,
la recherche d'un diagnostic.
Mais c'est vraiment qu'une étape
dans un parcours de soins et de vie.
Et là, on parle des patients,
mais vous accompagnent aussi leurs proches
qui, on y pense peut être moins,
mais sont aussi impactés
par ce type de pathologies.
Alors oui,
les fratries, c'est très important.
D'une part par le retentissement
de la maladie
qui est quelquefois très éprouvante
pour tout le monde.
Mais il y a aussi les aspects génétiques
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier que
beaucoup de ces maladies
sont d'origine génétique.
Donc il y a quelquefois des risques
pour que ces personnes
là et d'autres enfants atteints,
voire voire par exemple, je prends
un exemple qui me vient dans la tête.
Mais par exemple,
la myopathie de Duchenne, c'est
la myopathie dont on entend souvent parler
là, au moment du Téléthon.
C'est une maladie qui est transmise
par les femmes à leur garçon.
Eh bien, vous faites un diagnostic de
non seulement de myopathie de Duchenne
chez le garçon,
vous allez d'un seul coup vous apercevoir
qu'il y a plusieurs femmes
de la famille, des sœurs, des tantes,
la maman qui sont conductrices,
qu'on appelle conductrices,
c'est à dire qui sont à risque
d'avoir elles aussi un enfant atteint.
Donc, il y a, il y a l'impact,
on va dire au quotidien
de l'entourage proche,
parce que c'est pas rien de vivre à côté
d'un enfant qui est autiste,
déficients intellectuels, et cetera
ou qui est tout le temps à l'hôpital
ou où quelqu'un qui a la mucoviscidose.
Mais il y a aussi l'impact
familial et de l'information aussi,
ce qu'on appelle
en termes de droit à la parentèle
la diffusion de l'information familiale
et qui n'est pas toujours facile.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ? Non.
Vous le disiez tout à l'heure,
il y a cinq pour 100
vous m'arrêter, si je me trompe,
Il y a seulement 5%
en fait, des maladies rares
pour lesquelles on a un traitement.
C'est bien ça un traitement vraiment
spécifique qui corrige la maladie ?
Oui, c'est à peu près ça.
Ça peut être un tout petit peu augmenté.
C'est moi, mais je pense qu'on est quand
même toujours à peu près à ce chiffre.
Et donc on les appelle
les médicaments orphelins.
Leur prix est assez affolant
plus d'un million d'euros
pour une piqûre dans certains cas.
Comment expliquer ces prix là
alors ?
Effectivement, c'est
là. Pour l'instant, il y a très peu
de traitements et peu de malades.
Donc l'assurance maladie
arrive encore à suivre.
Mais par exemple, il y a une maladie qui
peut, qui maintenant est semble traitable.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle la spinale infantile.
C'est des enfants qui naissaient
complètement hypotonie et
qui marchaient jamais
et qui mouraient à moins d'un an.
Donc maladie très très grave
et donc il y a un laboratoire
qui a développé une thérapie génique et
ça les.
C'est à dire que
on n'a pas encore beaucoup de recul.
Mais en tout cas voilà, leur pronostic
est complètement transformé.
Sauf que ça coûte 1,9 million.
L'injection de.
Et on ne sait pas encore s'il
faut recommencer que la mucoviscidose
par exemple.
Il y a des nouveaux traitements
qui ont des effets spectaculaires.
Vraiment, ça transforme la vie des gens.
C'est 500 000€ par an pour un patient.
Voilà.
Donc ça pose des problèmes
médicaux, économiques énormes.
Problèmes éthiques aussi.
Et en même temps,
quand vous avez le patient devant vous
et qu'il y a un traitement disponible
si vous voulez le traiter, évidemment.
Et pourquoi c'est aussi cher ? C'est
parce que justement,
les laboratoires, souvent,
ont peu de débouchés.
Ils font monter les prix.
Et puis il y a eu, il faut quand même
le reconnaître, un travail d'amont
qui est assez énorme,
qui est de recherche,
qui a duré souvent des années
et des années, donc.
Donc c'est comme ça
en tout cas qui justifie le prix.
Mais il y a un moment donné,
il va falloir vraiment réfléchir
à un autre modèle et
à des partenariats
public privé aussi, qui,
parce que de toute façon, les industriels
peuvent pas avancer sans les académiques.
Parce que c'est quand même là
que se fait la recherche et inversement.
Les les chercheurs ont quand même
pour vocation que ça débouche
sur des applications pratiques
et donc qu'il y ait des industriels
qui développent des produits.
Voilà un des
autres juges de ce prochain plan maladies
rares,
c'est d'accentuer les partenariats
public privé.
Et d'ailleurs j'ai.
Je suis un peu en avant première.
Là, ils vont rajouter probablement
le ministère de l'Industrie
dans les tutelles de ce plan maladies
rares qui pour l'instant été copiloté
par le ministère de la Recherche
et de la Santé.
Voilà.
On entend beaucoup parler
de système de coupure du gène
par les systèmes cryptés
et qui corriger
peut être certains gènes déficients
et remplacer la partie
déficiente par une partie saine
génétiquement reconstituée.
Pour corriger le défaut.
Quand on espère CRISPR-Cas9.
C'est ce qu'avait lu le prix Nobel.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça.
Oui, Cette technique est elle employée ?
Peut être dans certains cas diagnostiqués
dans ce genre de problème.
Oui, oui, c'est bien ça.
C'est un outil, ça en fait un.
C'est un outil qui commence à être
utilisé effectivement
dans certaines thérapies géniques.
Oui, tout à fait.
Mais bon,
ça pose encore plein de problèmes.
Ça marche
souvent sur des cellules
dans la boîte de Petri,
dans le laboratoire.
Ce n'est pas encore de la routine
pour le passage
chez l'homme
parce qu'il y a, il y a plein de soucis.
En fait, la coupure va pas toujours
se loger là où on voudrait faire.
Il y a ce qu'on
appelle des effets off target,
c'est à dire en dehors de la cible.
Donc oui, c'est un outil parmi d'autres
qui semble très intéressant.
Vu de loin, ça paraît simple en fait,
mais c'est le moyen
pratique, technique peut être d'améliorer,
de viser la cible dans le 1000.
J'allais dire vulgairement comme ça
pour savoir entre quel, quel taux,
même de certains gènes couper précisément
sans créer un nouveau défaut ou quoi ?
C'est ça ? C'est tout à fait ça.
Sans créer des nouveaux défauts
ou voir d'autres maladies.
Parce que
par exemple, il y a eu des
essais où il y a eu
des leucémies qui sont apparues
chez certains patients
parce que ça a déréglé d'autres gènes.
Donc il faut quand même pas jouer
les apprentis sorciers.
C'est pour ça que tout bon, il y a tout
un cheminement dans les essais cliniques.
On ne passe pas directement de la levure
et de la souris
à l'homme. En fait,
le ciblage est très difficile.
Tout à fait.
J'ai une petite pré question avant
ma question
est ce qu'une maladie génétique
est une maladie forcément héréditaire ?
Je ne voudrais pas dire de bêtises.
Non, non, c'est une.
C'est une très bonne question
parce que c'est assez souvent
les patients nous demandent ça.
Souvent,
la réponse est non, c'est à dire que
il y a beaucoup de maladies
génétiques qui sont accidentelles,
qui sont qui surviennent.
Ce qu'on appelle dans notre jargon
des nouveaux, c'est à dire c'est
une mutation ou une anomalie chromosomique
qui n'est pas présente chez les parents
et qui est apparue
pour la première fois chez le patient.
Donc c'est génétique parce que c'est
un patrimoine génétique
n'est pas celui de tout le monde,
mais ce n'est pas hérité.
Du coup, si, si.
Effectivement, une maladie génétique
est rare.
Est ce qu'elle peut être due
à l'exposition à l'environnement
ou des choses comme ça ?
Est ce qu'on arrive à expliquer l'homme ?
Il y a,
on explique. Pas très bien pour l'instant
pourquoi il apparaît des mutations.
C'est.
C'est l'éternelle question
effectivement que nous posent
les personnes malades.
Pourquoi moi ? Ou pourquoi mon enfant
et il y a eu pas mal
de fin déjà d'études épidémiologiques
et autres pour essayer de comprendre.
Alors probablement
que des grosses catastrophes
type Tchernobyl,
ça favorise les mutations.
On connaît certains facteurs de risques
l'âge maternel de la maman par exemple.
Quand on rapproche,
on se rapproche de 40 ans.
Il y a plus de risque de trisomie
21 par exemple.
On sait que l'âge paternel élevé favorise
les mutations dominant, c'est à dire
le changement d'un gène.
Enfin une base en une autre.
Voilà, il y a comme ça
des facteurs de risque,
mais vraiment de savoir pourquoi
il y a eu telle mutation.
Notre notre organisme est quand même
bien fait, c'est à dire
qu'on a des systèmes de réparation
sans arrêt, de l'ADN
qui est endommagé, qui se répare,
et cetera Et à un moment donné, ça,
ça ne
c'est pas bien fait et on ne sait pas trop
pourquoi.
Et du coup peut être une dernière question
c'est
est ce qu'il y a des exemples,
peut être même récents, de maladies rares
qui seraient devenus des maladies
bien plus fréquentes ?
Finalement ? Hum.
Alors des maladies rares
qui seraient devenus plus fréquentes ?
Il y a des maladies rares
qui sont plus fréquentes dans des régions
que d'autres, ça c'est sûr.
Je vous donne un exemple,
la mucoviscidose par exemple.
Il y a vraiment un gradient Nord-Ouest
Sud-Est
en Afrique,
il y en a pas un quasiment. Donc
si vous prenez à l'inverse
la drépanocytose,
qui est une maladie de l'hémoglobine
qui donne des anémies graves, et cetera,
il y en a plein en Afrique.
Donc ce n'est pas une maladie rare en
Afrique, c'est une maladie rare en France.
Mais elle est en train de
devenir fréquente parce qu'il
y a quand même beaucoup de mixité.
Donc du fait des flux de population,
il y a des maladies
rares dans certaines régions
qui deviennent fréquentes
après des maladies rares.
Ce que vous voulez dire, c'est être dû
à l'environnement, par exemple.
Je n'ai pas d'exemples
comme ça dans la tête, mais
bon, dans le domaine
de ce qu'on pourrait appeler les démences,
par exemple, une démence fronto temporale
que je connais
malheureusement dans mon environnement.
Est ce que c'est une maladie rare ?
Est ce qu'il y en a beaucoup ?
Alors oui, c'est.
C'est à la fois
une maladie commune et une maladie rare.
C'est
à dire que c'est bien ce que je pensais.
Donc la démence fronto temporale,
malheureusement,
est une maladie relativement fréquente.
Mais dans ces maladies communes,
il y a des
des sous groupes de maladies
rares, c'est à dire des
qui sont dus à des mutations,
des anomalies génétiques.
Et d'ailleurs souvent on les repère
parce que ça touche
des gens plus jeunes que ce qu'on voit
d'habitude.
Voilà, c'est ça.
C'est exactement
le cas que nous avons, que nous vivons
dans notre environnement familial.
Un garçon qui a
déclenché une démence fronto temporale.
Chose qui nous a paru absolument énorme.
D'abord parce qu'on
ne connaissait pas la question,
et puis qu'il avait toujours été
pendant de longues années. Très bien.
Mais il a déclaré à 52 ans, ça,
ça a l'air effectivement.
Alors ça, on a compris.
On nous a bien expliqué
que c'était quand même rare pour le coup.
Tout à fait.
Et c'est affreux.
Vous avez tout à fait raison de dire
que les maladies neurodégénératives
touchent globalement beaucoup
les personnes âgées.
Il y a des maladies fréquentes,
tout le monde les connaît le Parkinson,
la, certaines démence,
l'Alzheimer, et cetera
Et dans toutes ces maladies,
il y a effectivement quelques unes.
C'est une petite poignée.
On, ce n'est pas la majorité qui sont
dues à des mutants, des
mutations génétiques qui se transmettent
quelquefois d'ailleurs de génération
en génération, avec un risque sur deux et.
Et ça, souvent on est alerté parce que
la maladie apparaît à un âge
où d'habitude, on ne voit pas ça.
Oui, oui, oui.
Donc c'est là qu'on déclenche quelquefois
des fins à la demande des familles
quand ils le souhaitent, des recherches.
Et voici,
ce n'est pas fréquent à cet âge là
une démence fronto temporale,
parce que je connais celle là un peu.
Maintenant c'est pas fréquent à 50 ans.
Ben non, souvent c'est quand même un plus
chez la personne très âgée.
Bon, d'accord, il y a des
il y a des équipes très spécialisées
dans ces groupes de pathologies.
À Rennes, dans le service de neurologie,
certains praticiens
qui travaillent dessus,
dont le fief, c'est
la Pitié-Salpêtrière à Paris,
où il y a beaucoup de recherches
à l'Institut du cerveau
et de la moelle sur ces maladies là
et justement sur les formes précoces
de démence,
sur les formes précoces de Parkinson,
et cetera
Et alors ? Moi, ce qui me pose vraiment
beaucoup question,
mais ça, il n'y a pas de réponse.
Vous dites les gens j'ai bon Parkinson,
on connaît toutes.
Et pourquoi certains ont ça ?
Et pourquoi pas d'autres ?
Ça, on n'a pas toujours la réponse.
C'est bien.
C'est une réponse que j'aimerais bien
avoir.
Oui, malheureusement,
c'est sûr.
La réponse est complexe je pense.
C'est à dire qu'il
y a probablement pas tout génétique
et tout environnement,
c'est à dire qu'il y a des personnes
qui ont des terrains prédisposant
mais qui développeront pas
parce que ils ne se sont pas trouvés
dans C'est toute une vie.
Bon, je vais vous dire,
j'ai 89 ans le mois prochain,
vous les faites pas madame ? Ben
non, je tremble pas du tout.
Je pas, je dessine.
Tout va bien, comme quand j'avais 50 ans.
Il y a des choses qui vont moins bien,
mais pas en.
Mais je n'arrête pas de me demander
pourquoi.
Pourquoi
on parle ?
C'est pour ça que vous restez jeune ?
En fait, c'est parce que vous vous posez
plein de questions.
Ah ben oui, ça, je sais bien pourquoi.
Pourquoi ? On parle beaucoup d'égalité ?
C'est un grand sujet.
Actuellement, on parle d'égalité
et d'égalité sur plein de plans, et cetera
Mais on n'en a pas l'égalité finalement,
parce que moi
j'ai passé toute ma vie
comme mes sœurs,
comme des membres de ma famille
qui sont complètement à l'Ouest,
ou alors qui sont morts.
Et pourquoi moi je suis là
et pourquoi je ?
Je pense.
C'est pourquoi je pars
et pourquoi je vis et pourquoi
j'aimerais bien savoir un jour pourquoi.
Je pense que vous êtes pas la seule.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ? Non.
Donc on en parlait tout à l'heure.
On augmente les dépistages, on augmente
l'émission des professionnels de santé.
Mais bon, on n'augmente pas trop
les moyens de l'hôpital.
Concrètement, aujourd'hui en France,
est ce que c'est possible
de continuer à faire
de la recherche sur les maladies rares
tout en accompagnant
les patients de manière toujours
plus complexe ?
Alors c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire.
Mais, mais c'est vrai que
c'est de plus en plus compliqué.
Vous le savez bien, il y a des priorités,
il y a les urgences
et donc toutes ces
toutes ces configurations.
Et puis la crise de recrutement
des jeunes médecins, et cetera
font que
les maladies rares
sont peut être pas non plus
la priorité de santé publique.
Mais par contre, quand vous êtes atteint
d'une maladie rare, pour vous,
c'est quand même la priorité.
Donc justement, le challenge,
c'est de ne pas oublier aussi
toutes ces personnes qui souffrent,
qui sont isolées
et et qui ont besoin
d'être prises en charge.
Est ce qu'on va tout faire ?
C'est très compliqué,
c'est très compliqué, c'est pour.
Pour moi qui suis chef d'une petite équipe
par rapport à un gros service,
par exemple de neurologie, de cardiologie,
et cetera Mais quand déjà
vous avez une équipe, quand même,
une trentaine de personnes,
plus des charges d'enseignement,
en principe la moitié du temps
à la fac de médecine, plus
donc la gestion du service,
les consultations et les soins
aux patients, soins,
enseignement et recherche,
effectivement, c'est indissociable.
Dans les maladies rares,
les gens ont des maladies très rares
qu'on ne connaît pas.
Ils ont pour certains pas de diagnostic.
Donc si, si.
En plus vous faites pas de recherche sur
leur maladie, c'est vraiment double peine.
Donc on a un devoir de faire du soin
recherche
ces soins, recherche, recherche, soins.
Voilà, c'est très pour eux.
Donc la morale de l'histoire,
c'est qu'il
faut être plus fort à plusieurs.
Donc qu'il
y ait une collaboration importante
au sein des équipes et puis entre équipes,
entre les équipes de soins
et les équipes de recherche,
que ce soit moins clivé aussi.
C'est un peu le but justement de ces
dispositifs maladies rares, c'est que
c'est de créer du lien
entre les différents acteurs
pour avancer vers des objectifs communs.
Parce que,
comme vous
le savez, à l'hôpital,
on est tous complètement sous l'eau.
On peut le dire donc voilà.
Mais mais
on craque quand même pas parce qu'on a,
on sait pourquoi on se lève le matin.
Je crois qu'il y avait une question.
Oui, mais après, c'est un petit peu
sortir du parcours de sens.
Je voulais revenir, peut être
faire le lien avec Café des sciences
qui a eu lieu sur l'homme, augmenté,
la femme augmentée.
Alors aujourd'hui,
la jeune femme peut faire congeler,
C'est ouvert et j'ai une vraiment bête.
Je ne sais pas mon domaine de spécialité,
mais quand on fait congeler ses ovaires,
est ce que peut être
il y aurait un risque moindre après qu'il
y ait des des malformations génétiques
qui se créent ?
Comment ça se passe ? En fait,
ce qu'on
congèle en fait, ce sont les ovocytes,
c'est les gamètes qui vont servir à faire
le bébé après.
Est ce qu'il y a moins de malformations ?
On ne sait pas très bien
parce que ça ne fait pas
quand même tant d'années que ça
qu'on peut le faire
entre guillemets, pour convenance
personnelle.
C'était surtout utilisé chez
les personnes infertiles dans un parcours
de PMA
où on a priori,
il n'y a pas
pour l'instant de chiffres significatifs
dans un sens ou dans l'autre.
En tout cas, il n'y a pas, il n'y
a pas plus de malformations quand on passe
notamment aussi par des parcours de PMA,
mais ni moins non plus.
Finalement, un
Mais peut être qu'on
en saura plus dans dix ans quand on aura
un peu plus de recul, parce que c'est
des pratiques récentes quand même.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Juste une petite parce
que comme on est sur la place rennaise
au niveau des maladies rares.
SK Rennes, On, C'est un endroit où on a
mis le doigt ou découvert une maladie
rare, particulière, où là,
on se dit Ah ça, à Rennes,
ils l'ont trouvé.
Et au niveau des équipes ?
Parce qu'après tout ça, ça se travaille
au niveau national
qu'européen et international.
Et ici, il y a eu des choses
qui ont été mis en œuvre.
Il y a eu des choses
pas pas très spectaculaires,
c'est à dire qu'on a quand même identifié
quelques nouveaux gènes dans le cadre
notamment du neuro développement.
Mais bon, c'est moi,
c'est moi, médiatique, que de découvrir
je ne sais pas quoi, moi, La mucoviscidose
ou l'hémophilie, c'est sûr,
ce n'est pas l'équipe de Rennes
qui a découvert, mais c'est vraiment
grâce à l'équipe de Rennes et à l'époque
d'un grand monsieur qui s'appelait
Marcel Simon,
qui était doyen de la fac de médecine
pendant longtemps, que l'hémochromatose,
le gène de l'hémochromatose,
a été découvert.
Donc là, on peut dire quand même
que bon, finalement, c'est les Américains
quand même qui l'ont trouvé.
Mais les Rennais étaient têtus et
c'est vraiment grâce à leurs travaux
que voilà qui est de la découverte.
Après
voilà,
il y a.
Ce n'est pas l'équipe de Rennes non plus.
Mais par exemple, les recherches
sur la mucoviscidose en Bretagne
sont très avancées, notamment à Brest.
Donc, il y a eu, si
on a été cosignataire ou signataire,
même en premier ou dernier auteur
de la découverte de nouveaux jeunes,
mais plus dans des groupes de maladies,
genre anomalies du développement.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Non, peut être.
Terminer sur Sur une note un peu positive,
la recherche sur les maladies rares,
c'est arrivé.
J'imagine que ça continue d'arriver.
Elle aide la recherche
sur des maladies communes.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez
des exemples concrets en tête.
Euh. Oui, j'ai un exemple
que tout le monde connaît.
C'est le
l'exploration de l'ARN
qui était un peu confiné
dans des labos de recherche pour trouver
justement des traitements pour certaines
maladies rares comme par le biais
de la RN et en fait, c'est ça
qui a permis en quelques semaines
de trouver le vaccin
contre le CO par exemple.
Et puis
on s'aperçoit de plus en plus que c'est
dans les deux sens, c'est à dire qu'il
y a des médicaments, par exemple,
qu'on utilisait dans le cancer,
dans le cancer du sein par exemple, ou
qui s'avèrent être
utiles parce que c'est des gènes
de la même voie moléculaire.
Dans certaines anomalies du développement.
Et inversement. Donc
oui, il y a
de plus en plus qui sert aux maladies
rares, sert aux maladies communes
et est toujours pour rester dans l'exemple
parce que ça,
tout le monde le connaissent.
Exemple
en fait, l'équipe de l'institut
Imagine à Paris,
qui est un gros institut des maladies
rares, qui
justement joint à la fois
le soin et les équipes de recherche.
Ils ont montré que
les personnes
atteintes de formes très,
très graves, de vide, qui face
ceux qui décédaient rapidement, et cetera,
y compris des sujets jeunes,
avaient des mutations dans un gène
qu'on appelle l'interféron,
qui est un gène
très important dans l'immunité.
Et en fait,
cette découverte a
permis d'étendre à tout le monde le fait
qu'il
y avait une anomalie de femme,
que ça touchait
l'interféron, finalement le comité,
et qu'il fallait agir là dessus.
Donc,
y compris dans des formes plus communes.
Voilà donc oui,
ce qui sert aux maladies rares
et toutes les recherches,
par exemple sur la thérapie génique,
et cetera Il y a des débouchés
dans le domaine du cancer par exemple.
Est ce qu'il
reste des questions chez vous ? Non.
Dans ce cas là,
je vous remercie tous d'être d'être venu.
Oui Sylvio, Donc
je précise qu'il
y a des numéros de Science Ouest en vente
sur la table, juste sur votre gauche,
dont celui sur les maladies rares.
On vient aussi de sortir notre numéro
d'avril sur les landes et les tourbières
bretonnes, à l'intérieur
duquel vous pourrez trouver
une enquête de lectorat où vous pouvez
donner votre avis sur le magazine.
Il sera bien pris en compte
et on lira toutes les réponses.
Voilà, nous,
on peut se donner rendez vous en septembre
pour le prochain Café des sciences.
Donc je vous souhaite un bel été.
Ce sera la surprise.
Pour l'instant,
on n'a pas de près.
Merci à vous en tout cas et bonne soirée.
Merci à tout le monde.
En tout cas pour toutes les questions.
C'était c'était bien
et pour l'invitation.